firefighters retreating briefly in
southeastern spain they're trying to
stop the flames from reaching houses in
the valdez area near valencia the huge
fire began when lightning struck at the
weekend fueled by strong winds it's
forced hundreds of people from their
homes
so far this year spain's had almost 400
wildfires and they've already destroyed
more than three times the area consumed
by flames in 2021
they've been fueled by heat waves and
drought conditions that scientists
attribute to climate change
in germany the drought means you can see
so-called hunger stones at various
sections of the river rhine
centuries ago they were placed on dry
river beds and marked to warn future
generations their exposure could signal
famine
over in france the country's longest
river the loire looks like this a record
drought has cut the river flow to a
trickle meaning in places people can
almost walk from one shore to the other
side
it makes me sad because i grew up here
and i've never seen it like that before
we could go to the water holes over
there with the children and fish
scientists are warning that low river
levels across france are a sign that
can't be ignored
climate change is underway it's
undeniable and that compels us to
rethink our rules for sharing water
resources
we must understand that we're all
affected water is a common good and
every one of us will have to rethink our
behavior
where the rain has finally arrived like
here in paris it's badly needed but
europe's having to get used to heavier
downpours
travelers on the metro had to contend
with flooded stations
meteo france reported that one month's
worth of rain fell in the space of an
hour
and the skies also opened in london
where parts of the uk capital
experiencing flash flooding
thunderstorms are expected in england
and wales and with the dry soil almost
impenetrable in areas people are being
warned to watch out for further flooding
nadine barber al jazeera